we've now learned that we do not have to
guess how the parkland Florida shooting
might have gone differently had there
been a good guy with a gun there because
we've learned that there was a
presumably supposedly good guy with a
gun there Scott Peterson was the school
resource deputy who was armed and in
uniform that day and Broward County
Sheriff Scott Israel has now told
reporters that Scott Peterson was at the
school he was armed but he stood by as
the violence unfolded saying quote what
I saw was a deputy arrived at the west
side of building 12 take up a position
and never went in and now Scott Peterson
is being investigated for his lack of
action now of course the reality is that
any investigation that is going on here
no matter what the investigation turns
up these situations are really complex I
am NOT going to even attempt in this
story to defend Scott Peterson or to
criticize Scott Peterson the arm deputy
but what I want to criticize is the idea
that the best way to stop the bad guy
with the gun is the good guy with the
gun the armed school resource deputy
clearly did not serve as a deterrent to
the shooter in parkland Florida and once
the shooting started the good guy with
the gun also did nothing to stop the
incident now whatever the reason was and
maybe the investigation will eventually
give us an answer to that this is
something that would happen in many of
these situations we learned after the
Las Vegas shooting of 2017 there were
multiple supposed good guys with guns
there they had no clue where to shoot
because it's chaos in these situations
and a couple of them actually spoke to
media and said rightly so I realized I
couldn't do anything with my gun it was
of no use to me to have that gun there
as a good guy yeah it's a good thing
that they didn't fire back because then
they'd just be blasting the hotel
absolute firing indiscriminately Aurora
movie theater shooting another example
people talk about oh the movie theater
was a gun for
zone so it's an attractive target well
we know that they're being guns in a
place has not been a deterrent to
shootings and how on earth would more
guns in a dark and loud movie theater
have helped anybody bring that situation
to a better resolution when you start
discharging a gun in the dark with
insane ricocheting echo it makes
absolutely no sense but what I want to
talk about now is that Donald Trump and
many others are smearing this arm deputy
Scott Peterson Donald Trump actually
called Peterson a coward by saying he
lacked the courage and then asking maybe
people are cowards sometimes here is
Donald Trump talking about it his whole
life is an example but when it came time
to get in there and do something he
didn't have the courage or something
happen but he certainly did a poor job
there's no question about that he was
there for five minutes the five minutes
that was during the entire shooting he
heard it right at the beginning so he
certainly did a poor job but that's the
case where somebody was outside they're
trained they didn't react properly under
pressure or there were coward it was a
real shot to the police department
cowards
maybe they were cowards and MSNBC's
lawrence O'Donnell put it really well in
a tweet actually and it so I'll quote
him lawrence O'Donnell from MSNBC saying
the president who did not run towards
the sound of guns in Vietnam 50 years
ago now labels an officer with a handgun
a coward for not running towards the
sound of an ar-15 Trump is by far the
most cowardly president in history I
don't know about that but what I do know
is Trump is the last guy who should be
talking about anyone's courage for Trump
courage would be I don't know not
ordering another bucket of KFC for the
flight home that takes real courage for
Donald Trump and the big takeaway is
that using all of this to try to arm
teachers is a disaster
and we've got to prevent that from
happening as Trump said a lifelong
trained deputy didn't fix the situation
with his gun so how on earth are we
supposed to believe that a schoolteacher
is gonna take out shooters without
causing more chaos never mind a student
potentially taking a teacher's gun and
using it to shoot people or a teacher
going off and committing a mass shooting
themselves at a school and imagine a
scenario where there is a shooter or at
least the teacher thinks there's a
shooter at the school and that teacher
in an attempt to stop what they believe
is a shooter shoots the wrong kid or a
random kid and then the parents sue and
the entire thing implodes or when the
teacher is trying to take out the
shooter and police show up and see the
teacher with a gun and think oh that's
the bad guy or the bad gal with the gun
and the police shoot the teacher who I
guess is trying to defend the children
or when multiple teachers have guns and
they start shooting each other it's this
delusional fantasy to think that this is
a good idea if you think about it at the
30,000 foot level and that's clearly all
Trump is sort of capable of you end up
with ideas like hey we'll hold on only
we had more people at the school to stop
the shooter hey schools have teachers
let's give them guns as soon as you
start envisioning actual scenarios
similar to the Aurora movie theater
shooting where people say hey gun-free
zone there were no guns in there to
prevent the shooting well if you have a
handgun and it's a dark movie theater
and you hear a gunshot you can't
identify what direction it's coming from
how would that have actually helped once
you get into the details Pat I feel like
it becomes much more clear that armed
teachers is if anything a acutely bad
idea never mind a neutral or good one
yeah and now you have some on the right
who are even criticizing this idea that
arming teachers will be the solution to
mass shootings in schools but do you
think that the lawrence O'Donnell
comparison was correct or adequate to
make well listen I mean being drafted to
war and doing what you can to avoid that
is not the same thing as if you are
hired to provide arms
and you don't go it's not the exact same
thing the problem I have is that it what
I like about it is it does go to Trump's
pattern of constantly calling out the
Valor of others while clearly being a
guy who has just lived an entire life
with this you know born with a silver
spoon in his mouth was able to basically
buy his way out of Vietnam but thinks
he's the authority on patriotism and
courage yeah I just feel that if you
were drafted into the military the
expectation is that you are opted in and
then he could opt out if you have
deferments or you're conscientious
objector but that was a draft right at
the time it was not just oh if you want
to join you join it was Trump was going
to be drafted and it appears as though
it was a friend of his dads who got him
this note about his bone spurs it's it's
not sort of like it's not the volunteer
military but the expectation is that you
have to go in unless you have a reason
to go out of it out of it yes whereas if
you're signing up to be a sheriff's
deputy or a law enforcement officer
that's your choice and you have to take
on the risks that go along with them I
don't disagree with you it is not a
perfect analogy but I think it does go
to Trump being the self-proclaimed
authority on patriotism and courage and
American values while basically
representing the exact opposite so in
that sense I think it does point out
some of the double standard and inherent
in Donald Trump today's program is made
possible in part by fruit or boot or is
a social forecasting game where players
come together and compete with each
other to predict future events you open
up the game on your phone or web browser
you'll see a whole range of forecasts
covering topics across the board from
politics to sports and everything in
between you wager on predictions about
real world events using for tours in
game fake currency and you earn more of
this currency every time you make a
prediction that comes true you can show
off your prediction skills to friends
and improve your forecasting ability I'm
even on Fateh or you can find my account
and follow me by clicking the link in
the description if you're watching this
on YouTube
this week on futur I pose the question
will there be a congressional hearing
regarding the Trump sexual assault
allegations what do you think click the
link in the description and place your
bets and you can browse the politics
category on futur to wager on other
predictions sign up now at futurecom and
start making your forecasts on political
topics and tons of other topics totally
free available on both Android and iOS
as well as on web browsers that is fut
uur dot-com